[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en el programa de hoy en el
norte de la cisjordania ocupada en el
campamento de yening la violencia se ha
recrudecido a máximos históricos en las
últimas semanas con una redada de
soldados y raíces que dejó diez
palestinos muertos entre ellos dos
menores en medio de la escalada de
tensiones entre palestinos e israelíes
el gobierno de Israel el más derechista
en décadas está tomando fuertes
represalias por el asesinato de siete
israelíes por un atacante palestino una
escalada de violencia que aumenta el
temor de una tercera enchufada
en Turquía la comunidad de judíos
sefardis luchan por mantener su lengua y
su cultura 500 años después de que
llegaran a Estambul expulsados de la
Península ibérica por los Reyes
Católicos
iniciamos en la cisjordania ocupada
Porque solo en enero 35 palestinos
fueron asesinados por las fuerzas
israelís día más mortífero fue el jueves
26 de enero en el campo de refugiados de
yenín símbolo de la resistencia
Palestina desde que fuera parcialmente
destruido en 2002 un equipo de France 24
viajó al terreno Un día después de la
redada Esta es la historia de las
víctimas en el campo
adolescente pega carteles con los
rostros de los mártires el jueves en la
víspera de nuestra visita estallaron
aquí unos combates inusualmente intensos
entre las fuerzas israelíes y los
militantes armados murieron Yes
palestinos y 20 y resultaron heridos
había un cuerpo aquí totalmente el
segundo estaba aquí todavía en llamas
y el tercer cuerpo estaba aquí su cara
no era identificable pero se podía ver
su cuerpo en el segundo piso también
había una persona herida
esta casa albergaba a miembros clave del
islámico según el ejército israelí
estaban acusados de planear atentados
inminentes en Israel la casa fue
alcanzada por un longzacohetes
algunos muros amenazaban con derrumbarse
Así que al ayuntamiento de yening
decidió destruirla bajo la mirada de los
jóvenes palestinos del barrio más
adelante en el campamento esta ventana
daba a los enfrentamientos Omar explica
que su esposa Era una simple civil más
dao bahid de 59 años Fue asesinada por
dos disparos en el cuerpo
oyó los disparos estaba en su silla
mirando abrió las persianas para ver qué
pasaba Y entonces el ejército le disparó
aquí hay un agujero de bala aquí aquí
también abrieron fuego esporádicamente
como pueden ver
y aquí una bala entró en la televisión
era una mujer en su ventana no llevaba
máscara y ciertamente no un rifle RPG
en la sala familiar las mujeres del
barrio acuden a dar el pésame el
ejército israelí dice que está
investigando si algunas de las víctimas
eran sospechosos armados seguimos en
esta convulsa región para analizar todo
lo que está sucediendo con la escalada
de violencia y para ello tenemos a
Yanira Gómez Muñoz corresponsal de
France 24 en Jerusalén Yanira Gracias
por estar con nosotras enero fue el mes
con mayor número de asesinatos de
palestinos por parte del ejército
israelí desde 2015 al menos 35 y también
7 y realiza asesinados por un atacante
palestino son cifras sin contexto pero
que demuestran que la violencia
sistemática y se manifiesta de muchas
formas sobre la población Palestina qué
hay detrás de esta nueva escalada de
violencia
uno podría decir que el detonante es
actual violencia fue la redada Angelina
del 26 de enero en las que las fuerzas
militares israelíes mataron a diez
palestinos y obviamente con ese
consiguiente respuesta contra respuesta
no de esos cohetes y bombas de entregaza
e Israel los dos ataques en Jerusalén
este las agresiones de colones israelíes
pero lo preciso lo real es que detrás
hay una violencia casi diaria que no
cesa es constante especialmente contra
los palestinos No si abrimos el foco de
esa redada Pues esa redada es la
continuidad de meses de redadas y otras
agresiones de las fuerzas israelíes en
cisjordania ocupada y esto a raíz de los
atentados de marzo y abril en Israel
pero si abrimos aún más ese foco lo que
nos encontramos es que son décadas de
ocupación y israelí ocupación militar
israelí en cisjordania ocupada con
muertes discriminación desalojos
demoliciones también encarcelamientos y
obviamente eso propicia picos mortíferos
como el actual hemos visto pero que
algunos son más se hacen más seco en la
comunidad internacional que otros pero
solo para que os hagáis una idea Por
ejemplo Desde esa redada del 26 de enero
hasta este dos de febrero este ahora que
estamos conversando ha habido múltiples
ataques de colonos israelíes también
contra cristianos y dentro de la ciudad
vieja de Jerusalén Jericó esta ciudad ha
estado por completo bloqueada Además de
que ha habido incontables demoliciones
en Jerusalén este Yanira y precisamente
Ustedes han estado reportando desde
cisjordania sobre las condiciones que
algunos describen de apartheid y también
sobre la ocupación de estos territorios
palestinos Cómo es la situación allá
sobre todo Qué pasa con la población más
joven sin futuro y fuertemente
deshumanizada por las violaciones a sus
derechos por parte de las fuerzas
israelíes
como decíamos las formas de la violencia
en cisjordania ocupada son múltiples van
de lo militar a lo burocrático pero en
efecto sí ante todo esto ha habido una
proliferación de milicias como sobre
todo en Jenny Nina blues Como por
ejemplo La Guarida de los Leones la
brigada de balata la brigada de llenín y
esto estas han atraído a esos jóvenes
palestinos que han visto como una única
respuesta contra la ocupación no a modo
de resistencia que evidentemente todo
esto engendra mucha más violencia no ha
habido otros jóvenes que por ejemplo se
han identificado más con esa denominado
ser lobo solitarios No ha sido el caso
del atacante a las afueras de las
sinagogas recientemente no pero como
decíamos esta violencia es constante y
el ejemplo Es que este atacante su
abuelo fue asesinado por un extremista
israelí a la salida de una mezquita en
una mezquita Esto ocurrió en el año 98
Mientras que el primo de este atacante
una semana antes de los hechos Pues fue
asesinado en una de las fuerzas
israelíes en Jerusalén evidentemente
esto no representa toda la juventud
Palestina hay una gran parte que teme
esta radicalización no de estas milicias
Y estos ataques y obviamente esta
juventud sobre todo se siente huérfana
se siente desesperanzada porque hay un
vacío de poder en cisjordania ocupadas
el caso de la autoridad nacional
Palestina que no tiene está totalmente
desacreditada mientras que en el enclave
en la franja de gaza pues jamás ha
convertido es considerado más bien un
estadishment no que no que no está
representando
Yanira y Cómo influye el hecho de que
este sea el gobierno más ultraderechista
en Israel y también en la busca de una
salida pacífica al conflicto vemos que
benjiviri es partidario de una anexión
decir Jordania tilda los palestinos de
terroristas prometió el porte de armas
para lucir ralis mientras que parece que
el Primer Ministro Benjamín netanyahu
inclina su balanza hacia este extremo de
su coalición
Pues si en el anterior gobierno de Yair
lapic no había ninguna Esperanza ni
siquiera de un diálogo recordemos que el
año pasado 2022 fue el más mortífero
para los palestinos desde la segunda
intifada desde el año 2005 Así que cómo
esperar que El Ejecutivo nuevo de
Benjamin netanyahu pues vaya no haga
algo que contraería esa línea no De
hecho no solo continúa las acciones de
la ocupación sino que las profundiza y
esto se sabe Se observa Mejor dicho
porque en su base entre otros por
ejemplo hay ese reclamo con que
mencionabas no esa expansión de los
asentamientos en los territorios
palestinos y además todo lo que se
propone todo lo que se dice se hace con
un con un tono revanchista de odio Que
obviamente incrementa mucho más odio No
mencionabas a ventivir él es una de las
personalidades uno del ministro de
seguridad nacional que evidencia ese
discurso no por ejemplo a raíz del
ataque de la sinagoga en las afueras de
las sinagoga él anunció que presentará
una ley para aplicar pena de muerte con
silla eléctrica a quienes Israel
considere terroristas pero si se quiere
también ha dicho o ha planteado no cosas
un poco más simbólicas como el hecho de
retirarles el pan en la dieta de los
presos palestinos no todo esto hace que
sectores extremistas especialmente
representados en los colonos y en la
parte más religiosa no se sientan
legitimados a tomarlos a tomar acciones
por su cuenta contra los palestinos a
sabiendas de que no van a recibir un
castigo no y sólo por terminar
recientemente estuvo el secretario de
estado estadounidense Anthony blinken
llamó a una calma una vez escalada no
pero muchos intelectuales y civiles
palestinos se preguntan Pues a qué calma
regresar cuando como mencionábamos la
constante aquí es de violencia tanto
física como verbal no Muchísimas gracias
Yanira vamos a seguir muy pendientes de
lo que está sucediendo allí
y terminamos en Turquía hace 500 años
que los judíos sefardis llegaron a
Estambul la mayor ciudad de Europa
después de su expulsión de la Península
ibérica a manos de los Reyes Católicos
medio Milenio después esta comunidad
conserva aún su idioma originario del
español su religión y su cultura pero la
presión de Turquía y el nacionalismo
Turco empujan a esta comunidad y su
idioma a la desaparición en el siguiente
informe de Adrián rocha y Albert naya
vemos las historias de algunos departís
que pese a las dificultades luchan por
mantener su recuerdo vivo
estamos viniendo la casa que nació mi
casa era de madera
es esta casa
abajo vivíamos nosotros Salomón un judío
sefardín de Estambul guarda Mil
recuerdos de estas calles su antiguo
barrio balat era poblado mayormente por
judíos griegos y armenios hace un siglo
de ellos ahora ya no queda nadie ya me
iba a irme cuando tenía 14 15 años
Mira hijo ante comités del pan y bebites
la agua no la dejes
este país es tuyo aquí naciste y aquí te
vas a adelantarte
y bueno que no me cuida aquí en la
actualidad en Turquía quedan alrededor
de 14.000 sefardis los descendientes de
los judíos que fueron expulsados de
España durante el siglo XV algunos de
los pocos asentados en Estambul hablan
en Ladino un idioma que ahora está a
punto de desaparecer el periódico shalom
lucha para mantener vivo el idioma
la siguiente generación era mía ya no
entiende demasiado Ladino y ya no lo
habla esto significa que en máximo 20 30
o 40 años el Ladino desaparecerá lo que
nosotros hacemos Es intentar que esta
desaparición tarde lo máximo posible
en la familia de Rafael está desapa está
latente a diferencia de él y de su mujer
sus hijas no hablan ni entienden el
Ladino desde hace una década España y
Portugal entregan la ciudadanía los
sefardíes y como muchos otros miembros
de la comunidad Él y su familia son
ahora además de turcos portugueses él
dice que quiere quedarse morirse en
Estambul las nuevas generaciones quieren
marcharse de Turquía hay muchas familias
que se van mi hija con Villano se fueron
a Portugal a portugués
por caminar y por Mirar los sefardíes en
Estambul aceptan y que en unas décadas
desaparecerán pero su idioma su pasado y
sus 500 años de historia en las orillas
del bósforo se niegan a disiparse
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir
toda la información en nuestra página
web France 24
[Música]